just some of the problem hotspots posing
big risk for President Biden in an
election here Carl Ro former White House
Deputy Chief of Staff of Fox News
contributor Carl sometimes there's a
photograph that will just encapsulate
everything and I think it right now for
this election in 2024 it's this one take
a look here this is a migrant who was
involved in the attacking of police
officers in Times Square he's being let
out of court yesterday on bail and he
gives America the Press everybody there
the double bird and I feel like if you
wanted to encapsulate the problems of
the Biden Administration you take
unfettered illegal immigration crime and
then being able to walk out without any
consequences and there you have a
photograph that you might not see other
photo editors choose to show it but this
is where it
is yeah in fact there's some even more
uh terrible photographs of of five
illegal immigrants beating up two cops
uh to the arrest of these people was one
of them and uh and and this is so wrong
on so many levels five people who have
come into our country illegally who are
being taken care of by on by taxpayer
dollars kept in in shelters and in
hotels in New York uh this particular
guy the double bird guy is a homeless
guy so he's come here and become an even
bigger burden on our society with all
kinds of consequences and costs they
attack two police officers they get
arrested and then they get let out with
zero bail they're not even a dollar
these people are just let out which is
the idea of these sort of big city
Progressive prosecutors that that we got
to be fair by by not requiring bail of
poor people well we've now put back on
the street five people who have shown
what they think of the American justice
system and what they think of what
behavior is appropriate when they come
into our country yeah it might be worse
than that they they may actually be
living in City shelters uh we haven't
been able to that just four of them are
four four of the
there's yeah four of them are okay cuz
we asked the Deputy Commissioner that
last hour and she wasn't sure about it
but I mean that's I mean that's another
blow right because the taxpayers are
paying for it uh here is the back and
forth now in the Border you know it's
going to be a political battle right now
Carl between Democrats and Republicans
pointing
fingers I want to be very clear our
borders are not open the border is
secure the president has done more to
secure the border and to deal with this
issue of immigration than anybody else
so you've got that and you've got this
from
Congress yeah it's a it's a quote um
this is from a memo that the White House
put out it said that after years of
playing politics House Republicans have
a chance to finally say yes to border
security and this is the Deputy
communications director uh Andrew Bates
he said that inheriting a broken system
President Biden acted on day one by
proposing a concrete immigration reform
plan and underscoring the press in Need
for border security unfortunately not
only have Congressional Republicans
blocked the president's reform plan
since then but they have also voted
against the record border security
funding he has delivered over their
objections every single year the media
is going to help the White House deliver
this message can Republicans withstand
it yeah they can because all they need
to do is say here's where the level of
immigration was in December of 2020
roughly 40 I think thousand people a
month coming across the border here's
where it is today five times as big
200,000 if you have if if the system was
broken for how come we had fewer people
coming across the border if the border
is fixed and secure now why do we have
five times as many people coming and and
it's ridiculous now both sides have
something to be blamed for in this the
Republicans frankly ought to take what
they can get uh out of this deal because
remember it requires 60 votes in the
Senate and it's so bad for the Democrats
they're willing to at least give some
steps that will help us get better
control over the border and the
Republicans are capable of saying okay
nice start but you failed to do X and Y
and Z and Q and the only way we're going
to get that is to have a Republican
president and a republican Congress
you're willing to give it to them they
can win that long-term battle and in the
meantime get some things that they're
not going to get otherwise at least for
a year because they require 60 votes in
the Senate but yeah the idea that the
White House is sitting here saying oh we
are in control of the Border we've
gotten it fixed and oh incidentally you
are keeping us from getting it fixed
because you won't vote for our our plans
those two things are a conflict with
each other but the fact of the matter is
at the end of the day the Republicans
will win this messaging battle because
here's where the level of illegal
immigration was when when they left
office and here's where it is today gap
between is the Biden Gap a lot of
Republicans say why Bend because the
laws are on the books if you just
enforce
them yeah well you I I don't think they
should ban the question is what more can
you do that will constructively help
give us additional tools like more
funding for for barriers and for the
wall where it's necessary more money for
border patrol and so forth that there
are things that can be done proactively
that'll step up our ability to enforce
the Border but the Republicans you know
are going to win this battle uh the
messaging battle the question is in the
meantime are the Democrats smart enough
to say you know what let's give them
more of what they want in order to get
the 60 votes and give us at least say we
got forward progress but they're
ultimately not going to be able to win
this battle cuz again here's where it
was here it is today and even if we make
big changes today this this top number
is not going to drop a lot in the next
seven or eight months yeah thank you
Carl good to have you have a great day
thanks for having me I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis